gunfire lit up the sky over europe's
largest nuclear power plant in anherodar
in southern ukraine the ukrainians say
heavy shelling by russian forces set off
a huge fire in a building on the site
as a result of strikes there is a fire
at the nuclear power plant i repeat as a
result of strikes by the russian
federation forces on the zaparisia
nuclear power plant a fire has erupted
it took firefighters four hours to put
out the blaze emergency crews reportedly
coming under fire from russian troops
who seized the area after fierce
fighting
world leaders condemned the attack as
reckless ukraine's president accused
russia of what he called nuclear
terrorism
we survived the night that could have
stopped the story the history of ukraine
the history of europe russian troops
attacked the parisian nuclear power
plant the largest in europe it alone
could be six chernobyls
calming international fears of a
catastrophe nuclear monitors in vienna
said the plant's reactors were secure
we of course are fortunate that there
was no
release of radiation and that the
integrity of the reactors
in themselves was not compromised
the kremlin denied attacking the plant
and blamed it on ukrainian saboteurs
nine days into moscow's invasion of
ukraine russian troops continue to push
into the country moscow says these
pictures show its tanks near kiev for
days a 60 kilometer long military convoy
has stopped outside the capital for
reasons that still aren't clear but it's
fueling anxiety and fear in the city
some wonder how their lives could have
changed so fast
this is a genocide against ukraine the
ukrainian people and ukrainian land it
is simply awful scenes like these are
fired at homes all over the country
cities including hakeev in the east and
the strategic port of mariopol on the
sea of azov continue to be pounded by
russian shells schools homes hospitals
all hit
contradicting moscow's claims that it's
not targeting civilian areas and we will
not surrender we will stand here on our
land in our city for as long as it takes
among the destruction many ordinary
ukrainians continue to resist
others are desperate to leave the un
says that at least a million people have
fled ukraine for neighbouring countries
since the russian invasion began
more than a week ago thousands of people
have passed through the city of levive
it is not far from the polish border and
they just keep coming
we are very scared because our parents
are staying here
i hope it's not our all
our
last days of our
life i mean for all the world
ukrainian and russian negotiators agreed
on thursday to set up humanitarian
corridors no word yet though on how or
when these would be implemented in the
meantime people across the country live
in fear face uncertainty and a new
generation is growing up with another
war natasha butler al jazeera lev
ukraine